while only a fraction of books for kids
or are by or about people of color there
has been some progress children's books
written by authors of color increased
three percent in 2020 while books about
diverse characters or subjects grew
about one percent one Creator is part of
that Trend vashti Harrison has made it
her mission to teach children about the
black leaders and dreamers who made
history we visited her in Brooklyn to
see her process and her creations
something will just come to me out of
the blue author and illustrator vashti
Harrison has quite a vivid imagination I
often start with a kid or just a face
shape and then I wonder like well what
is interesting to me right now that
right now depends on which point in time
over the last decade you've caught her
in look at this her resume crosses the
spectrum of the visual arts I think of
myself as a multimedia artist so I like
to approach stories and storytelling
from as many different perspectives as
possible because a firm believer that
not every story needs to be told in a
single medium she's moved seamlessly
between film and children's literature
creating characters and stories that
break the mold including hair Love
written by Matthew Cherry that story put
her on the map I think people were
hungry to see a story like that
celebrated in that way it's a really
simple story it's about a relationship
between a father and a daughter doing
something as every day as doing your
hair
[Music]
love became a film and won an Oscar for
best animated film short in 2020. I
think that's really unique and special
too to highlight these moments
her luxuriant style of color and form
give young readers time and texture to
lose themselves in so when did that
spark of creativity start with you I
think I've always been driven to make
art and tell stories as a young person I
used to draw a lot I would sit in front
of the TV and copy my favorite cartoon
characters and as I got a little bit
older I would flip through fashion
magazines and copy outfits and
hairstyles I realized that I could start
expressing myself and telling my own
stories but that spark I think has
always been there did you see yourself
represented in those pages I think as a
young person I found different ways to
connect to different characters but I
don't think I ever saw too many
characters that looked exactly like me
in 2017 a mission to celebrate
African-American women during Black
History Month evolved into the
best-selling children's book little
leaders you know when Carter G Woodson
founded negro history week in 1926 his
goal was to celebrate the stories that
had been long neglected throughout
history and I thought who better to
celebrate than black women she shared
the lives of some 40 Achievers from
mathematician Catherine Johnson to
writer Maya Angelou and one character
that embodied why representation matters
I think the story of Mae Jemison the
first black woman in space her story was
so inspiring one because
she went to space when I was a kid and I
didn't know her name when I was growing
up what are the chances of the captain
and the others being alive it wasn't
until she had seen Nichelle Nichols play
Lieutenant nahura on the TV show Star
Trek that got her finally to believe
that she could be an astronaut don't you
understand Nichols nearly left Star Trek
because of backlash but changed her mind
when she met with Dr Martin Luther King
Jr he told her how much her work was
important to him and people around the
world that she mattered and her story
mattered and she went on to have
incredible roles in Star Trek but then
later worked for NASA to help recruit
people and Mae Jemison went on to be on
Star Trek the Next Generation it's like
it's so beautiful that these women that
their lives intertwined that we can see
how it's important it is that they knew
each other's stories existed and so I
just I wonder how many other young
people are inspired by these stories
another other inspiring story soulway
which was Illustrated for oscar-winning
actor Lupita yongo earned an NAACP award
for outstanding literary work one of
many books in her catalog sometimes you
can get really into these little details
and I wonder like is anyone going to
notice the little lace pattern on the
clothes some of the earliest sketches
for big are in this little notebook a
work of fiction based on her own
childhood I wanted to create a story a
book that could be the comforting words
that that I definitely needed to hear it
follows the story of a girl when she's
young all the adults around her say
things that we've all said like you're
such a big girl now you're a big girl
now and big is good until a certain
point comes and somehow big isn't good
anymore I'm so curious is is it imposter
or is it in some more more ethereal way
that you're showcasing what I'm saying
is that the character grows bigger and
bigger as her anxiety and her insecurity
grows bigger and bigger stories Harrison
hopes young readers can find comfort in
do you see your books making an impact
on the Next Generation I think I can
think of my work in abstract terms and
knowing that this is important that it's
going to reach people because I know how
books affected me but when it I get to
go out to schools and chat with young
people it feels really special for me
when they pick up a book when they pick
up one of my books they've never seen it
before and they say that one's me or
that one looks like me that makes a huge
difference because I remember that
feeling Harrison wants to work more on
animated feature films and television
she even hopes to enter the
three-dimensional space of toy making
more recently I've been excited about
kind of crafting with my hands and so
you've created all of these I have so
all of the figurines are crafted from
tin foil base with paper mache on top
and paper clay they're not you know High
art materials but through the process of
of crafting a character you can make
something that is you know 100 a piece
of art do you get inspiration from your
neighborhood everyday life
oh absolutely and she adds there's no
cap to her creativity I have lots of
ideas so I'm never nervous about what I
have coming up but I feel really
fortunate to be in this position to be
able to take the time to say what do I
want to work on today feels incredible
and maybe everything that I ever wanted
as an artist